okay thanks Mike and let me echo your
thanks to everybody involved in the
organization of this it's been very fun
an interesting few days so since I'm
kind of the other book end of the
conference I wanted to revisit Duncan's
last slide from his talk where he talked
about Goldilocks problems for
computational social science and laid
out some desiderata for them today I
want to talk about I'm going to talk
about a specific problem and solution to
that problem in the area of privacy of
data privacy I want to make a general
pitch that I think privacy is a good
topic for the merger of computer science
and the social sciences to think about
it has a number of very nice property so
one property is is that you know social
science itself needs solutions will be a
consumer of solutions for data privacy
especially in so far as it touches on a
social data data that's about
interactions between people and i think
that the computational social science
won't just be a consumer of solutions
it's well positioned to be a provider of
solutions as well because there are both
computational and data central problems
there but there are also these sort of
bigger issues of policy you know sort of
government business individual concerns
so these really this really is sort of a
large-scale social problem and if you
look at the Goldilocks list the duncan
put up in his talk I think you know
privacy also fits the desert errata that
he described so you know it's clearly
you know sort of privacy in the largest
it's very clearly not an obvious problem
with obvious solutions I'll say a little
bit more about that in a second but I do
think it's also progressive in nature I
mean it's very early days still but I
think we're starting to see interesting
rigorous yet practical approaches to
privacy i will talk about one such
approach today and so you know the goal
of having a problem where there's an
easy version that yields concrete
deliverables in the near term i think is
there but on the other extreme you know
the hardest version is completely open
in scope it's obviously still a science
problem even though there are I think
opportunities for both glorified
consulting and clearly opinion as well
in privacy
and in general it's not creepy although
i'll leave you to judge whether the
particular piece of work I'm going to
talk about today has a bit of a creepy
element to it I think it might but in
general you know trying to find
solutions to privacy is an effort at
deliberately making the world a less
creepy place rather than a more creepy
place okay and so I think you know just
wanted to first of all recall these
goals that Duncan set out at the
beginning because I think they're good
ones and the ones that guided us in
these ongoing discussions that led to
this workshop and and let me further
argue that you know Duncan you know he
gave this great talk in which he said
look a lot of the questions that are the
oldest and the social scientists in the
social sciences despite a hundred years
of study you know people don't even
agree on what the problem is and privacy
is very much in this category today this
is a quote by a very well-known privacy
researcher named Daniel solo who says
you know privacy as a concept in
disarray nobody can articulate what it
means it suffers from an embarrassment
of meanings so there's sort of too many
definitions there's too many different
things that people mean when they talk
about privacy and the particular piece
of work I want to talk about today has a
kind of interesting backstory so last
year I participated in and perhaps was
the least contributor to a National
Research Council study that was the
result of a direct request from Obama's
office this was a study that was
requested in the light of the you know
post Snowden revelations and the
question you know phrased to the study
group was deliberately very very narrow
the question was are there technological
alternatives near-term technological
alternatives to the bulk collection of
metadata that would still allow
intelligence agencies to do their work
okay and the result of that study was
which is a very very interesting topic
yet somehow resulted in you know this
publication which has possibly the
driest title that I could possibly
imagine bulk collections of signal
intelligence technical options
and you know the answer the question
that was posed to us you can guess what
it was I mean you can go read this thing
it's about 100 pages long but the the
summary is that no there are not you
know near-term technological
alternatives and the reason really is
because of the way that the onion of the
NSA and other intelligence agencies use
this data which I'll talk about in a
moment one of the other interesting
things about this study was when I say
that the question was very narrowly put
us it was it was made very clear that
you know we were not being asked for our
views on whether the bulk collection of
metadata was a good idea was legal was
ethical etc it was you know just a bunch
of scientists being asked to weigh in on
this very specific question and so you
know I participated kind of lightly in
the study one of the things that amaze
me about it is how many incredibly busy
people drop everything they were doing
for several months and started appearing
you know every week or every other week
in DC and so I kind of felt bad and left
in the dust because I wasn't capable of
doing that on such short notice and so I
didn't end up really doing much on the
study but it did kind of leave me with a
very particular problem in my head that
I came back and talked to a bunch of
colleagues at Penn about um most
especially my faculty colleague Orin
Roth who's one of the Guru's of
differential privacy and I'm going to
tell you about the problem that we that
we kind of posed as a result of this
study and the solution that we came up
with ok and so just to you know now kind
of back up a little bit and and frame
the problem a little bit better you know
I asked you to consider the following
hypothetical scenario some unnamed
intelligence agency holds the
interaction metadata of its citizens so
think about you know records of
telephone calls between individuals
think about you know social media
exchanges between individuals or email
exchanges so essentially a social
network is the underlying data set and
this intelligence agency perhaps has a
legitimate interest in using this
network data to search for you know bad
actors in the network okay and an
important kind of consideration here is
that the network itself
provide leads to finding those
individuals but actually detecting
whether somebody is a bad actor is a
much more expensive and a much more
intrusive operation okay so what I mean
by this is you know you can kind of use
the network as a gradient if you know
about one bad actor you can pause it
that bad actors are more likely to
communicate with each other than you
know non bad actors and sort of use the
network structure to do to sort of
prioritize who to take a harder look at
and I'll say a little bit more about
this in a second but this is essentially
how the NSA uses this data you can kind
of think of it as a fishing expedition
with a gradient that's given by the
network structure and so the question is
is you know how can the hypothetical
intelligence agency balance its mission
with the with both the expense of kind
of more intrusive investigations of
individuals and also still provide some
privacy guarantees and my main kind of
non contribution to this study was that
at a couple of points in the study I
said like well you know it seems like
ideas from differential privacy which
I'm about to describe to you could be
adapted to this problem where you
essentially have a subpopulation that
has no privacy rights but you still
don't want to give up on privacy in its
entirety for the people that are not the
focus of your investigation and you know
the couple of times I mentioned this
idea it was you know I think correctly
at the time shot down by the other
people on the committee who knew
anything about differential privacy
because they said like you know
differential privacy is a non-starter
here because by definition it guarantees
privacy for everyone right and you know
clearly terrorists should not have any
expectations to to privacy okay and so
this was sort of the the you know kind
of my state of mind when I came back
from this study and just to say a little
bit more about what I'm going to mean by
privacy here by privacy here I'm going
to mean that the identification of the
bad actors or whatever you know
subsequent action that the intelligence
agency takes on these bad actors
shouldn't reveal very much about the
data the specific you know network data
of any particular individual that's not
actually
a bad actor for instance a terrorist
okay that this is kind of the idea
behind differential privacy in this
setting so let me let me talk about
differential privacy for a second so you
know usually the Simon's Institute
sponsors and holds workshops that have
some very very strong connection you
know not just a computer science but to
the theory of computer science and so
you know at the very last second I think
I'm going to provide that link for this
workshop I don't think there's any
direct references to theoretical
computer science yet so differential
privacy is a theoretical model it's a
mathematical definition or framework for
thinking about data privacy in a very
general way it was introduced by Cynthia
dork and other colleagues back in 2006
and it's really it kind of seen quite an
explosion of research in the last decade
especially on the theory side but we're
now actually starting to see I think
practical implementations of ideas that
have come from differential privacy and
so I first want to just kind of walk you
through what the at a high level what
the basic definition is what the basic
concept of a differential privacy is and
then I'm going to talk about how to
modify that definition for the specific
setting where the underlying data is
network data is sort of communication
data between people and a social network
and where you're not you don't want to
provide privacy guarantees for every
individual in the population okay okay
so first of all differential privacy is
a definition about algorithms right it's
a definition you know an algorithm
either is differentially private or it
is not differentially private so it
doesn't talk about whether the data
itself is private it talks about whether
an algorithm manipulating data treats
that data in a particular way that has
some sort of privacy guarantee okay and
yeah
just as we get back to your question um
so in some sense like why did you feel
that the NSA or whatever it's more
important that the algorithm operate
privately than actually just like having
the data there because obviously their
security good good good so so there are
many so the two comments so there are
many there are many things that one
might want in a differentially private
algorithm or for the problem that i'm
going to describe and we're not going to
provide all of those things so in
particular i'm kind of already starting
from the point where we assume that this
hypothetical agency has this data for
better or worse and wants to use it for
the stated purpose and so debates about
whether this data should have ever been
collected in the first place or whether
it's you know secure you know being
securely treated in McLean Virginia I'm
kind of punting on and those are very
very important questions more generally
differential privacy kind of also punts
on the question of you know it should
you what data should you be collecting
in the first place are you kind of
securing it in a pro you know in a
proper way or encrypting it in a way
that can't be read it's starting point
is that an algorithm has data or or you
can also think of it kind of a mechanism
design point of view an algorithm wants
to incentivize a population to
contribute their individual data sets to
some centralized computation and you
know one of the factors that those
individuals will think about is whether
their their privacy will be guaranteed
you could possibly use these ideas to
think about how to store the data
differently as well but you're just
going to take this yeah yeah and and I
think that that's slightly more in the
realm of cryptography than it is of
privacy and by the way you know it's
easy to kind of confuse those two things
but at a high level I think you know
cryptography is very much about you know
a computation not revealing more than
the result of the computation itself
okay whereas I think privacy is much
more about what does that computation
actually reveal okay and and and so both
of them are very important in both of
them have application to privacy but I
think of kind of data storage sort of
secure data storage as being more of a
crypto
problem and this is more about like well
I'm going to perform a computation and
release the results of it what act what
information about individual citizens is
leaked by that by that publication that
these are all very very good questions
and I'll try to be you know somewhat
clear within the confines of not getting
too technical about kind of what aspects
of the problem we're addressing and
which ones were not okay but so what is
differential privacy so we say that an
algorithm a is differentially private so
so so imagine an algorithm that takes as
input you can a database if you like or
vector right and so I'm going to call
that vector D here for the fur data set
and think of that data set as consisting
of a bunch of individual data sets of
the particular members of a population
so di here is the data set of person I
so if you want to think concretely d of
I might be the phone calls that you've
made in the past year it might be you
know who your contacts are in some
broader social network etc it might be
your medical record in a medical
application but think of d sub i's sort
of being your data set that you care
about protecting in a private you know
having some privacy guarantees about and
so in differential privacy we think
about the algorithm is taking this
aggregate data set a crop rubber for an
entire population and the property we
want and i'll put up the next one in the
second but i'll just say it in english
first the high-level idea of
differential privacy is if you go into
any data if you take any data set and
you kind of modify just one component of
it so I go in and I change only your
data and in particular think about the
change where I delete your data so we're
sort of comparing the computation that
would be performed with your data
present or without your data present I
basically want the outcome of the
computation to be only negligible
negligibly altered by the omission of
your data set for instance and so the
way we formalize this is that we we say
that an algorithm eyes darling you'll
see that the definition i'm about to
give requires it's sort of a fundamental
component of differential privacy that
we have randomized algorithms
a random it's a randomized algorithm is
differentially private if for any data
set D and any neighboring data set D
Prime and by neighboring I mean this
sort of counterfactual Nash equilibrium
type go in and just modify the data of
one individual in the vector we
essentially have that the distribution
induced over outputs is almost identical
okay so think of this randomized
algorithm for any fixed data set because
it's a randomized algorithm even for a
fixed data set its output will be
randomized okay it'll be there'll be
some distribution over possible outputs
of the algorithm and I want that when I
compare that distribution with the
distribution induced by changing one
element of the data set that those two
distributions are kind of controllably
close so you know one one way of
phrasing this is for any possible thing
that the algorithm could output we want
that the probability that the output of
the algorithm is that particular output
oh when the input is d versus the
neighboring data set D prime is
approximately the same okay so to
demystify this a little bit think about
the example where the input data set are
the salaries of people in a large
company and let's say that every week
the company wants on Friday to publish
the average salary of the employees in
the company okay so you know the natural
thing for the you know the you know so
so one thing that the company could do
is actually every week take everybody's
salary compute the average and publish
it to numerical precision sort of show
all of the all of the all of the decimal
values in the average salary and this is
not this would not be a differentially
private algorithm right and the reason
at a high level it's not private is that
if the only thing that happened between
last Friday and this Friday is one
person joined the company okay then by
looking at the salaries on the two
successive Friday's we can back out the
precise salary of the new employee ok so
the differentially private solution to
this is mercifully simple you compute
the average salary and then you you add
some noise to it okay and at a
level what you'd like is that the amount
of noise you have to add sort of scales
nicely compared to the size of the
population and so it's pretty easy to
see just from sort of basic probability
theory that in this case that if I add
noise which is kind of on the order of 1
over the square root of the number of
employees I will still have a
numerically pretty accurate estimate of
the average salary but you couldn't back
out any individual salary from that
number or even from successive noisy
estimates of it okay on two successive
Fridays ok so that's the idea of
differential privacy your your algorithm
is going to be a randomized algorithm
that outputs you know in the example I
gave it was a single number but it could
be you know a vector of numbers it could
be a much more complicated output a good
example would be you know I would like
you know I'm a medical researcher I want
to invite people to give me access to
their medical records I'm going to you
know try to build a predictive model
let's say using least squares regression
to predict the probability of a disease
given a bunch of symptoms and test
results and you know I you know one
thing i could do is publish the the
actual coefficients of that regression
to numerical precision and one you know
the kind of question the differential
privacy is designed to ask an answer is
is it okay to do that I mean it kind of
seems like well you know what
information about any specific person's
medical record could be compromised by
releasing the coefficients of this
aggregate you know least squares
computation but the average salary
example should show that you should be
worried about this okay and so in
differential privacy you have a
randomized algorithm whatever space it
outputs from we'd like that the
distribution over outputs is negligibly
modified by a small change in the
underlying data set and you know so
here's just a cartoon of this this is a
cartoon in the case where the underlying
data set is a social network and you
know here I've got in the original
social network and here I've got a
modified social network where I've just
added one edge between two individuals
and what we want from the differentially
private algorithm is if this is kind of
a cartoon of the output distribution
that the two distributions under the
nearby inputs are also very close to
each other yeah yeah yeah yeah good so
that's the next line so the more precise
version of this definition is that we
say that the algorithm is epsilon
differentially private for some small
epsilon if the probability of any
particular output changes by most a
multiplicative factor of like 1 plus or
minus epsilon okay and so that's a
parameter of the algorithm right so one
of the nice things about differential
privacy and I'll say a little bit more
about this later these are be that you
know one of the problems with debates
about privacy and I very much experience
this on this study is that it's kind of
like political discourse in the United
States right now right you just have
like you know there's sort of one camp
that especially on topics of things like
terrorism or let's say you know fighting
infectious diseases epidemiology there's
sort of one camp it says these missions
or the source of the societal importance
of counterterrorism is just so
overwhelming that it should you know
Trump any individual any notion of
individual privacy whatsoever okay
that's one viewpoint and then there's
another viewpoint that says no no I
don't you know I don't care what threats
were subject to individual privacy
should trump everything and of course
you know if these are the only two
choices will never get anywhere right
and so I think one of the big problems
in privacy is just creating a language
and solutions that give choices in
between these two extremes right and so
one way of giving a choice is by
basically having this parameter that
says how private the algorithm is okay
and and of course that has to be traded
off versus the utility of the algorithm
which I'll talk about in a second which
is sort of how how good it's out how
useful the output is okay okay so this
is this is everybody understand the the
basic notion yeah example with salaries
the question is could we identify the
family one person right the answer there
is yes or no
there's some epsilon for which yes and
there's some handsome no no it's more
that okay so you know if you're an
individual in this computation right
here's sort of the guarantee that you're
given and let me say a little bit more
about this right so you know so the
fundamental nature of this definition is
that the inclusion or exclusion of your
data from the computation doesn't change
the output of the computation very much
this doesn't guarantee that bad things
won't happen just that whether your data
was included in the computation or not
doesn't matter much okay so if there's
sort of some if they're certain if
there's some set of outputs if the you
know if the output of the algorithm
falls in some particular set that you're
worried about you don't want you know
that the computation to result in that
particular output or set of outputs you
know this definition isn't saying like
well I'm promising you that bad thing
won't happen to you I'm just saying for
instance if epsilon is is one for
instance I'm telling you that the
probability of that bad thing happening
can't won't change by more than a factor
of 2 by you including your data in the
computation and I particularly choose
that value because you know in general
hopefully the bad event that you're
worried about has a small probability
and so a factor of 2 is not a big deal
right so if it was kind of extremely
unlikely that this bad thing happened to
you without your giving the data then
it's only twice as likely to happen by
you're giving the data okay and so that
that's how its quantified is in this
epsilon okay so it doesn't guarantee you
know and this is I think another
high-level point I'd like to make you
know be suspicious of any definition of
privacy the guarantees that you know bad
things can't happen you should be
suspicious of any such definition but
but one that doesn't guarantee that but
just says sort of quantifies how much
worse off you could be by computed by
participating in the computation is a
sort of sensible alternative okay okay
so let me just you know so now that I've
given the at least the flavor of the
definition let me just make a couple of
high-level observations and
went out some nice facts that are known
about differential privacy so first of
all observation number one differential
privacy is easy to obtain trivially you
could just ignore the input right so if
I just don't pay attention to the input
data and output like a random number
this will satisfy differential privacy
okay because no matter what data set you
give it as input you know it's inducing
the exact same meaningless completely
information free distribution over the
output and so this the dobbs are pointed
the sabra the servation is that the real
trade-off here is between privacy and
utility so the utility part is not part
of the definition of differential
privacy it's just talking about the
privacy guarantee but the goal of the
research and differential privacy is to
pick up different types of computations
and say there's a way of doing this
algorithm there's a way of doing this
computation in a way that on the one
hand promises differential privacy and
also promises some utility results so in
the case for instance of linear
regression for instance the goal would
be to give a linear regression algorithm
that guaranteed differential privacy but
for which you could also prove that the
out-of-sample error of the resulting
model was almost as good as what you
would have gotten on the same data set
ignoring privacy so the kind of gold
standard is to kind of take the best
algorithm that you know for doing the
computation in a non private way and to
kind of all get an algorithm that's
almost as good with respect to what you
care about in that problem while still
providing a privacy guarantee and one of
the I think you know when I first saw
the definition of differential privacy
i'm relatively late to working on
differential privacy the first time I
saw it you know my reaction was like wow
you know that's the right definition of
privacy in the sense that if you could
achieve that it would be great it would
be a very very strong natural guarantee
and of course the first concern with
such a definition is that you know maybe
you won't be able to do anything with it
maybe you'll never be able to get you
know nothing will meet the definition
you won't be able to find differentially
private algorithms for interesting
computations luckily it's turned out
that pretty much the opposite is true so
many many calm
important fundamental types of
computation can be done in two
differentially private way you need a
different algorithm than the classical
algorithm but there is a way of doing it
differentially private so for instance
much or even most of what we're familiar
with in machine learning and statistics
have a differentially private version so
this includes things like you know least
square regression and many other types
of machine learning tools linear
programming there's there's a
differentially private version of linear
programming of convex optimization more
generally in the list is kind of growing
as time goes on differential privacy
also has very many sort of very nice
kind of program programming properties
so one of them is composition so if I
have two differentially private
algorithms a and B and I give the output
of a two algorithm B so I'm chaining
together two differentially private
algorithms the resulting composition is
also differentially private and the sort
of you know degradation of privacy
scales only linearly so if i had an
epsilon differentially private and a
private algorithm in an epsilon prime
differentially private algorithm then
their composition is epsilon plus
epsilon prime differentially private
okay it also is robust to post
processing so this is kind of like if
those of you who know the data
processing inequality information theory
you know which sort of says that you you
know you you can't create new
information by subsequent computation
differential privacy as a similar
property so if I give you a
differentially private computation and
you take its output no amount of
subsequent computation on that output
including computations that combined
that output with other unforeseen
datasets can Radek eight the original
privacy guarantee so this is extremely
important since these days a lot of
privacy breaches happen because of
essentially triangulation of datasets
right sort of you know party a releases
some apparently anonymized database
party B releases some apparently
anonymized database by combining them
together you're able to back out you
know the data sets of specific
individuals in the pop you
elation okay so it sort of by its nature
differential privacy prevents kind of
attacks like this okay and at a high
level the way one gets differential
privacy is kind of like the way I
described the average salary example you
add noise to your computations sometimes
to get the best result or even to get
the result at all that noise needs to be
carefully structured or correlated so
there's you know kind of some cleverness
required in the design of the album's
but at a high level what you're doing is
adding noise to computations at
different stages in a way that allows
you to get the privacy guarantee okay so
that's the that's the basic definition
of differential privacy and to kind of
modify it for the problem that was
inspired by this NRC study we need to
kind of do two things one is kind of
adapt the definition specifically to the
setting where the underlying data is a
network meaning your data is sort of who
you're you know phone calls have been to
or who your friends are on Facebook for
example and so and then we also want to
kind of model this fact that some
individuals in the in the population
have no privacy guarantees but the other
ones should have a privacy guarantee and
so let me just you know I'm not going to
get very technical you can look at the
paper for the details but at a high
level right the private data of an
individual the kind of d sub I that I
was talking about before are there edges
in the network you know you know you
know large-scale social network I'm
assuming that the intelligence agency is
already in possession of this entire
network in a centralized way for better
or worse and then to model this idea
that some parties in the population have
no rights to privacy I'm going to do
this in a very abstract way which has
both advantages and disadvantages but
though abstract way I'm going to do is
I'm going to assume that each individual
in the population or each vertex and the
network has a hidden status bit okay and
that hidden status bit basically is just
a one if there are kind of a target of
the investigation there are terrorists
for instance and it's a zero otherwise
okay and my assumption is that you know
the algorithm that's doing this kind of
network search on this graph is able to
investigate the
the status bit of any person to
population but that it's an expensive
operation right so think of that as sort
of an operation you want to minimize so
think that and I think this is very much
models the way things actually are at
the NSA from what I learned on this
study which is that you know the data
itself is their cycles are cheap so sort
of doing anything they want on the graph
itself is something that just involves
kind of computer time but actually
deciding to really figure out whether
some individual is perhaps engaged in
terrorist activity that's a very you
know personnel intensive and expensive
operation because it either means you
know it can mean anything from putting
people under surveillance to doing more
extensive background checks on their
travel on their financial records etc
and that's not is you know that sort of
analyst time that's not CPU time okay
and so what we want our algorithms for
the Intelligence Agency to efficiently
discover kind of vertices with a status
bit that's one but in but in a way that
provides differential privacy for
everybody whose status bit is a zero
okay that's kind of the high-level
algorithmic problem that we're trying to
solve here okay and you know I don't
have time to give kind of a detailed
example but you might be wondering like
well what could go wrong with the
standard thing so what does what's the
standard thing so the standard thing is
what they call in intelligence circles
contact chaining and that you might
think of as fishing expedition using a
social network right so what they do is
they start with some individual or
individuals that are kind of seeds that
they know are you know there are bad
actors okay they know that they're
involved in terrorist activity of one
kind or another and what they use the
social network for is they do kind of a
breadth-first search right they sort of
say well let's see who this person calls
a lot and then they go to those
neighbors in the network right and they
say let's look let's look at their
status but let's do a bit of an
investigation and so they might see okay
this person that gets called all the
time is you know the pizza delivery
place around the corner from this bad
actor and so no need to do any further
investigation there and then somebody
else they find you know might actually
be another suspicious individual and so
they'll sort of grow a connected
component
of targeted individuals okay and this
part actually doesn't present any
problem for privacy right because if all
you do is sort of grow a connected
component of targeted individuals even
though you will have looked at the
status bit of innocent or non targeted
individuals along the way if all you do
is publish our apt on the connected
component that you found them it's not
easy it's not hard to convince yourself
that this actually will obey
differential privacy even without any
randomization the hard part is when you
want to jump to a new component and the
best kind of high-level example I can
give of this is a little bit abstract
but you know many you've probably seen
movies in which they're sort of to
organized crime groups right that are
you know there are two cells of an
organized crime group and there's sort
of only one contact person who you know
is the communication path between these
two connected components of you know you
know maybe mafia members and it happens
to be that that person who's the bridge
between these two groups is an informant
okay for the you know for the
authorities right and you know the worry
is that if you kind of use that bridge
to find the second connected component
and then act on that second connected
component it can it might compromise the
privacy of the bridge okay and you know
in this case that's your informant and
you don't want to do that right so you
have to be very careful about jumping
from one connected component to another
and this is sort of where randomization
is required okay and so I'm not going to
describe the algorithm in detail but i'm
just going to describe to you at a high
level you know what what the
modification is that gives you
differential privacy and and and say a
little bit about performance on my last
slide so you know think about we know
what we actually do in the paper is is
kind of give a general transformation of
a certain class of non-private
algorithms into algorithms that are
private so think of that class of
algorithms as being more or less what
I've described here they are their
algorithms that start off with one or
more seed individuals that then do some
sort of
breadth first search to find a connected
component of targeted individuals and
then but then you know the kind of the
assumption we make in the paper this
sort of very general abstract assumption
that we make is that the search for you
know once you find a connected component
the way that you find your next
component is through what we call a
statistical proximity so what's the
statistical proximity a statistical
proximity is just sort of a graph
theoretic metric that tells you given a
set of individuals in the graph given a
set of vertices think about is like the
component that I've already found and
given any other vertex in the network
what's the distance from this vertex to
this set of individuals ok so there are
many many reasonable definitions for
this in the graph theory literature so
the most common one would be if you give
me a set of vertices and another vertex
the distance from this vertex to the set
is the shortest path distance from this
vertex to any individual in the set ok
that turns out to not be such a great
choice for a reason I'll describe in a
second but you can do it a different one
would be what's the number of common
neighbors between this individual and
this set ok so instead of looking at
shortest path distance i'm looking at
intersection of neighbor sets ok but but
either think of think of these two
examples of Statistics of proximity and
think about algorithms that when they
want to find a new component when they
want to sort of start a new search from
a different location in the network
think of what they do is just kind of
rank ordering all of the unexplored
vertices in the graph by their proximity
to the you know terrorists that you've
found so far and you know then sort of
systematically investigating sort of
checking the status bit of each one of
those individuals until you find a new
terrorist and then you kind of do
another round of breadth first search
from that new individual ok so that's
sort of a very practical you know broad
class of heuristics for doing search in
social networks for us a targeted
subpopulation that doesn't doesn't make
any mention of privacy whatsoever and
doesn't really have any privacy
guarantees that can be made for it and
all we do in the paper
is just proposed that you know when
you're doing that jump from one
components to another and you've kind of
ranked everybody by their distance to
the terrorists you've already found just
take the numerical values of those
distances and add a little bit of noise
to every one of them okay and so the the
nice property that this is going to have
by adding by sort of taking the number
of neighbors that everybody has in
common with the terrorists you found so
far and adding a little bit of noise to
it you're taking this ordered list and
you're not completely reshuffling it
right but your locally reshuffling it
you're not going to take the person that
was closest to the group you've found so
far and swap them with the person
farthest away but you will do a lot of
local reshuffling in this list okay and
it turns out that that's enough to prove
a differential privacy guarantee for all
of the kind of non terrorists in your
population okay it makes sense at a high
level okay so that's kind of the theory
part of the paper and then the utility
part I mean to prove a utility part you
just to be clear you'd have to make some
assumption about the relationship
between this network proximity metric
that I just described and weather and
the probability that somebody actually
is a terrorist or not right I mean the
whole point of using the graph to guide
the search is the belief that in some
network in some graph theoretic sense
terrorists tend to be closer to each
other than non terrorists yes Susan how
to think about the set of adversaries
that
be sort of trying to violate privacy so
like one of your motivating examples of
like revealing an informant or something
so like sometimes like suppose you had a
mole or you know who like a contractor
who was being able to do these kinds of
queries so you know we're doing it on
our end is we're going to find people
and then sort of audit them and so you
don't have to like fully reveal people
but just like even kind of getting some
information so think about think about
the computation you know kind of without
loss of generality you can think of the
output of the computation on describing
as a list of identified terrorists ok
that's the output and think of the
adversary if you like as being a party
that's going to take that output and
with kind of unlimited computational
resources try to figure out who your
contacts in the network are and
basically the adversary will have
succeeded if they can infer kind of you
know anything about your social contacts
that they couldn't have inferred without
the results of this computation so it's
sort of you know the adversary can kind
of do anything that they want and their
goal is to try to figure out you know
just one phone call that you made right
from from seeing the list of terrorists
that were output I mean I know I could I
think I understand like the narrow part
of this area i'm just going to think
about like where the sum of the limits
of the theory about like if they were
bringing in some other information or
you know using it in conjunction with
something else right and so this is sort
of where this kind of multiplicative
guarantee oh so you know if you think of
the goal of the adversaries being trying
to figure out who you've called from
seeing who the identify terrorists are
you know all you know what the
definition is saying is that the prod
their their ability to do that won't
have been increased much by the seeing
the results of this computation now
here's a bad thing that could later
happen after this computation your phone
records just get released in a public do
you know somebody posts your phone calls
on the internet okay okay so then your
phone calls would definitely be
wield all were saying all this
definition is saying is is that this
computation is kind of not at all at
fault for that right so but the bad
thing could still happen to you later
for some completely orthogonal reason
but what can't happen you know here's
what can't happen it can't be that some
later dataset from which your phone
records could not have been inferred can
now be inferred when combined with the
output of this computation that's what's
explicitly forbidden by this definition
yeah a little worried about your
informant if they're the only bridge
between these two cells well those cells
kind of infer that okay good good good
okay so this is a very good point and so
so so in that example right sort of if
that's your met okay so let me get back
to these two examples I gave of what
your network metric is one is shortest
path distance and one is number of
common neighbors okay so you know one
thing I may be the one thing I should
have said much earlier is that you can't
expect to do a differentially
computation you can't expect to do a
useful or accurate differentially
private computation if the underlying
function that you're trying to learn
trying to compute is fundamentally very
sensitive to one of its inputs okay so
you know if if the thing I want to
compute is the CEOs salary right then
there's just no way I can kind of output
a good approximation to that without
revealing a lot about the CEO salary I
kind of either have to just you know add
so much noise to it that you have no
idea what the salary is or I have to
basically tell you something about the
CEO salary so you know in all
differential privacy you need to start
with something which is kind of a low
sensitivity function that's a necessary
but not sufficient condition so and
that's why I gave these two different
examples of statistical proximity so if
you think about shortest path distance
that's an extremely sensitive statistic
because I can basically take a graph
which consists of these two components
connected by let's say just a chain of
individuals if I kind of remove you know
and so there's some short path between
these two cells right but if I remove
one of the individuals on the chain I
just change one person's data
now the distance between these two
becomes infinite okay and so if I use
that if I use that as my cystica
proximity you know we still have a
theorem but you'll have to add a lot of
noise to counter the fact you have a
very high sensitivity distance metric
whereas if you use something like number
of common neighbors you can show a much
nicer much tighter bound on the
sensitivity and you don't have to add
nearly as much noise yeah so the idea of
differential privacy seems to be
basically that if you perturb the disa
in one entry I won't be able to tell the
difference from the output that's right
but I mean if if this tribution of the
incoming get is such that you know
either I include say your information
visit or I drop both you and all other
professors of machinery right then that
means the sort of the perturbations that
an adversary would actually have to
reason about would be much larger if
they be correlated across every data and
then they might easily be able to test
base in half but which of these possible
worlds that are actually so just to be
clear right the probability in the
definition of differential privacy is
entirely over the internal randomization
of the algorithm right so the guarantee
has to hold for any fixed data set is
input right but I'm saying that this
there's a kind of Norfolk to be useful
it seems like there's an underlying
assumption that the perturbations that
could actually happen to the data set
like if I'm an adversary trying to
reason about what them to like
that is if I know something about the
video generating process right which
typically adversaries going through
something right there's going to be some
correlations and then coming in or
whatever I might be able to get a better
test so that that I mean so it is true
right that the kind of the amount of
noise you have to add is proportional to
the size of the perturbation so if you
kind of instead of doing the you know
thought experiment about one person
withholding their data you think about
some fraction of the population
withholding their data you know the you
can still chained together the
definition many times right and move
from sort of instead of two from D to D
prime D to D prime to d double prime etc
and get you know this sort of resulting
degradation of probability but you know
even if there's a probabilistic model
over the generation of the data that's
before we even get to the definition of
differential privacy now that's just
some fixed data set right and I'm still
going to give the privacy guarantee with
respect to that fixed data set we need
this data show and Michael get done
because they bring yo can we can take it
offline it's like okay good so anyway I
was talking about you know like well if
you really wanted to prove not just a
privacy guarantee for such an algorithm
but a utility guarantee you'd obviously
have to make some kind of mathematical
assumption that relates whatever you
know your chosen statistic of proximity
is in the network to the probability of
being a terrorist right you need you
need to sort of say like well people
that are closer in whatever your metric
is to the known set of terrorists are
more likely to be terrorists than people
who are far away okay and so we didn't
bother to do that there are some
subtleties to that but I think it's kind
of a fairly straightforward exercise but
we did do some kind of large-scale
experiments and so let me just call your
attention to sort of the blue and red
here so we took two large publicly
available social network data sets one
is the DL BP database of mathematical
collaboration co-authorship networks the
other is the IMDb you know kind of movie
database where the individuals are you
know actors or producers or directors of
the
like and there's an edge between pairs
of individuals that have been in a movie
rather than co-authored a paper together
so these give us nice natural social
network structures large-scale social
network structures of course they don't
tell us you know who the two who the
terrorists are and so we actually and we
thought about using kind of natural
subsets so for it for in our earliest
experiments we used d LBP and we decided
that you know the identified the
terrorist subgroup that we're looking
for is anybody who's ever written a
paper in cult which is the the machine
learning theory conference but we wanted
to actually be able to control the
components structure and by the way for
those of you who who know that community
you can think about you know who the
Osama bin Laden of the cult community is
Manfred warmuth was was right up there
towards the top but but but because
because sort of the the crucial issue
here is sort of the discovery of new
components we wanted to be able to run
experiments in which we control that
component structure more so where we
could kind of say well let's create a
subgroup of targeted individuals that
sort of mainly one large connected
component and a bunch of smaller
fragments to intermediate cases where
it's a few large components to cases
where it's a very very fragmented
community right and basically those are
increasingly difficult problems even
ignoring the issue of privacy right if
all of your terrorists are in one
connected component then once you found
one of them you've kind of found all of
them if they're highly fragmented into
tiny non communicating cells that are
really spread out then it's just a
difficult search problem even ignoring
privacy and so we wanted to control that
and so you know maybe I'll just focus on
the right column here and on the the red
plots which have error bars and the blue
plots which do not the blue plots are
basically a non private algorithm using
this kind of number of common neighbors
metric the x-axis here is you know kind
of how many vertices have you visited
and done a background check on them
you've checked their status bit so
that's going to you know kind of cost is
going on the x-axis and the y-axis is
how many targeted individuals has the
algorithm found so far so the blue curve
is the non private algorithm in these
three different regimes of kind of
mainly one law
urge connected component of targeted
individuals a moderate number of you
knows of medium sized components and a
highly fragmented community you can see
the y-axis changes here and get smaller
right because it's just harder to find
the individuals when they're highly
fragmented and the main point this
diagram is is that the red curve which
is the average of our private version of
the same algorithm over several hundred
trials with you know kind of ninety-five
percent confidence intervals around it
is is you know quite closely tracking
the blue in in all three of these
regimes right so indicate and sort of
the easiest problems it's doing just as
well as the non private version of the
algorithm in terms of its utility in the
sort of medium regime it's you know
tracking quite well with a little bit of
lag you know different points but still
quite quite competitive with the non
private algorithm and here it's doing a
little little worse but you know both
algorithms are finding so few targeted
individuals at all that it doesn't
really matter okay so this is just some
empirical validation the green line is
is on you know one of these things where
I'm using two different y axes the green
ass axis is essentially showing you your
risk multiplier so you know as time goes
on and you run the algorithm further
your privacy you know degradation your
privacy degradation increases but what
this is basically showing you is how
much it's essentially showing you what
the value of one plus or minus 1 plus
epsilon was in the original definition
so this for instance is saying that you
know at no point in this computation are
you more than twice as likely to suffer
some bad outcome whatever your
definition of bad outcome is by
participating in this computation versus
not participating in this computation
not that you really have a choice in the
case of the NSA running an algorithm on
your metadata but but if they wanted to
provide some privacy guarantees they
would they would be able to do so okay
so let me stop here and let me just make
maybe one more general comment that I
think is also kind of
a good topic for this you know community
and this workshop to think about which
is you know people have cared about data
privacy for a very long time and lots of
large companies and organizations that
we know about you know care about
privacy at some level and my impression
of what goes on in these large companies
these days is still that you know I mean
you stall these situations let's say at
Facebook or Google where you have armies
of machine learning phd's building
predictive models from you know
individual data that's aggregated and
using you know the results of those of
those modeling exercises in very visible
ways right so like you know what what
kind of search results you see what
sorts of ads you see so on and so forth
and I my understanding from talking to
people in these organizations is that
you know it's not that they don't care
about privacy the privacy isn't their
job right and it's not the job of the
algorithm instead there's some separate
privacy advocacy group perhaps within
the company that occasionally kind of
you know looks at what's going on in
these groups probably doesn't understand
much about it but they're kind of
separate functions okay and differential
privacy is kind of an effort to
endogenous this kind of you know so far
exogenous you know policy moral ethical
legal consideration in the algorithm
itself okay and I think that this is a
major growth area in computer science
and in computational science and even
more broadly and so for instance one
thing that a bunch of us at ten have
started thinking about is what would it
mean for a machine learning algorithm to
be fair for instance instead of private
so instead of trying to sort of provide
some privacy guarantee I want to provide
a fairness guarantee so for instance I'd
like to sort of say that if I'm using
machine learning to build a model to
decide who to give a mortgage to based
on a bunch of you know characteristics I
know about individuals I want it I don't
want it to just be the case that the
final model actually doesn't
discriminate against any member of the
population I want that to happen even in
during the learning process right so
before I kind of even know
but the truth is while I'm trying to
arrive at it by learning I'd like to
provide some kind of anti-discrimination
guarantee in the learning process itself
and this is another example and I think
that we're starting you know I think all
these things like you know workers
complaining about though I mean one
thing that's great about uber is that
their drivers compared to taxi drivers
are you know that they like to talk a
lot about their job and so you know one
thing I've learned you know like surge
pricing for instance you might think
that surge pricing would generally be
liked by uber drivers the ones i've
talked to generally say that they don't
like it because it's kind of yanking
them around right it's sort of
encouraging them to drive to someplace
that they're not and often by the time
that they get there the surge pricing
has ended and they've kind of not picked
up a ride in between and now it's back
to regular pricing okay so of course
there's no actual evil going on here at
uber they've just got some optimization
process but it's not the case that in
that optimization process there
explicitly thinking about how their
workers are treated and I think that
more and more as time goes on there will
be pressure on us as a community to try
to endogenous a lot of these political
moral legal ethical considerations into
algorithms themselves instead of having
some separate advocacy group that
worries about it as humans